come on release the army of the dead cut
they are
they are yeah man this isn't justice
league
there's been no problems releasing this
movie
you sure about that louis ck
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey guys because it's a zombie movie
we're increasing the shutter speed on
the camera give a little bit of that
that oh my god gory
we have no headphones plugged into her
let's get some headphones in here
reading this trailer
ward how would you like to make
50 million dollars
[Music]
his credits that way yeah
[Music]
[Music]
that scorpion yeah hell yeah get over
in the here to finish the strip with a
32-hour window
to get it out
in and out of course
it's not too late to go back
ugh
[Music]
[Music]
wow
they have romance
fight zombies it's like i am legendary
yeah
i have legends the same same property as
uh yeah
last month it's been made a lot
this is gonna be a blast look at this
look how much fun this is gonna be dude
[Music]
damn
cool i love that
shot where it's circling around them
because in each they're all doing
something with weapons
they're all but you can tell
something about each one of their
distinct personalities and how they're
handling their weapons
in each one of those angles i love what
position they're in and i love how the
safe cracker is the only one without a
gun
this is got the ball at the ball bat
with the nails in it yeah man
that was a fantastic trailer i get what
they're saying by now with that what was
the advertising they say right here
they're not what you think they're not
just
mindlessly again he's going out there
helping to reinvent some of the zombie
genre
yeah man where they they feel a little
bit more like like my introduction
to last man standing was actually
charlton hessen's of mega man
where last week yeah last man standing
you know the championship oh yeah
that was like my introduction to it
where there's something that feels
more uh medieval about the way they
behave almost
warrior cultish viking-esque demons from
hell
personality a little bit more dead-eye
but without
the dialogue of a dead eye yeah gleeful
evil yeah maniacal like i just want to
watch you suffer like they do have that
primal like hungry fierceness that
zombies
man like yeah but in the same time it
really did take me back to an omega man
i am legend type of thing where yeah
it's like there
must be and that even kind of builds on
what george romero zombies had later on
which is like there's some inkling of
the past
life or they have some sense of each
other in community or whatever
leftover well there's more of an
apocalyptic
cult flavor to here especially with the
the ones that look like queen and king
amongst the zombies like
it looks like there's a hierarchy here
with the army of the dead like it's
called
army of the dead yeah and it feels that
way
yeah a couple leaders and then all your
endless zombie grunts
like you'll have not kind of what i
loved about the
resident evil games was how you would
have certain different types of zombies
you really feel like you'll have
distinct ones here ones that could fight
hand-to-hand
the ones that are more leader-esque then
you got the
animals that really yeah that took me
back to like resident evil when the
tiger comes up because it's so
nasty and scary but also really cool
this looks great i mean every actor
looks awesome
dave batista if i'm not mistaken you
said he turned down suicide squad
for this yeah because he wanted to try
working with the snyder
i mean he's the lead yeah and i would
should take this on look at this man
absolutely he looks like he's giving a
great performance
yeah that paid off he got a very rich
looking i mean like that first shot you
see him in this trailer i was like damn
he looks like he is
further throwing down in his like acting
dramatic chops for you know a movie that
seems like
a lot of the characterization would
probably come from the actor's presence
and homework so like i i do appreciate
his dedication
i'm wondering what's happening here with
where he's at in the beginning because
it's such a trope for former convict to
be working at a local small restaurant
chef or a cook in the kitchen or just
wiping dishes but this is a different
world we live in
this is a world full of not the world's
full of zombies they're
all locked off here in vegas it is a
different world so
i don't know if this is the lifestyle he
chose i think what i remember hearing is
that to add a little bit more personal
heft to the situation is this will also
involve him finding his daughter in some
way
oh you gotta have a daughter or an
estranged family member to make us care
about mercenary
yeah that's the only way i love this
kind of
dream like close-ups that he does on
on all of his characters comparatively
to what we saw with zack sanders justice
league well there are some close-ups
there's a lot of close-up shots there's
a lot of zoom in shots here
it just seems to be a lot more in your
face like it's so close and then the
background's so
blurred yeah that there's almost this
dreamlike quality
yeah the way all this is being executed
you feel the vastness of the space and
if it's because you know vegas does have
such a gauzy fantastical
or uh you know mystique applied to it
anyway
and yeah like the desert the harsh
climate like i think it really
helps to enhance a lot of this stuff and
plus i mean this is full of just those
classic like zack snyder when the you
know coins are spilling out of the
machine
onto that guy's face as two zombies
closing like those
equally dreamlike but also super
symmetrical
and picturesque shots he likes to do
this is
so fun this is so fun and it is it is
it's kind of crazy to get zack snyder's
justice league which is more fun than
bvs or man of steel
but to get still zack snyder's justice
league which is this operatic
superhero epic a little bit later on a
different streaming service to get just
a throwback
blood vested really fun zack snyder
yeah and he said the guy who approached
him to you know uh kick this off was the
same guy who
helped green light dawn of the dead so
in a way it is a homecoming and i bet
it's been interesting working with
netflix because you know they
are famous for being like yeah do
whatever you want just you know get us a
movie we can sell
yeah man so uh and you know this is like
over two hours so this will still be the
snyder cut
this will be you know a substantial
movie and that's the one thing now i'm
thinking about is
it does look lean mean and fun and you
know most zombie movies are like
oh 90 minutes this is going to be two
hours and 20 minutes this is going to be
an epic film
yeah yeah so that's the one thing is i i
imagine there's got to be more to it to
sustain that run time
or there's going to be less slo-mo i
love zack snyder's slo-mo i do too
it's really engaging and hiroyuki sonata
between westworld
mortal kombat and now this this could
really shape up to be a good year for
him
yeah dude he's going to be the the new
sam jackson yeah
just showing up in everything for the
new josh brolin
yeah yeah yeah that's pretty that's the
next step is he's got to play the major
heavy
yeah mcu film sonata sans all right guys
well thanks so much for being here hit
that like button are you guys excited
for army of the dead subscribe
last but not least
i want to shout out my man scuba steve
scoobs
now john please oh sorry new faces
all right new face you're ruining scuba
shadow
with the same face you always do what
we're caught up in now you he made this
about you
who's shout out scuba steve scuba i just
wanted to say
that you're a man who i know who's
always on the lookout for love the
easiest way to get love put a woman
in a dangerous situation like a zombie
infestation then go save her life and
then when you save her life
you take a bullet then when you take
that bullet you gotta act like you're
gonna die
and be like i love you but then you're
gonna wake up in pearly gates you're
gonna see
like your grandparents and they're gonna
be like it's not your time yet this is
all part of the plan to get the girl by
the way
and then they push you back down from
heaven you come back to it and then you
find out the girl who you saved
has the same blood type as you dude and
that's the key that's the key to
carrying the zombie virus is
your shared blood yeah and then you
just distract me with all your stupidity
[Music]